ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN SENATE BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BURKE CALDERON RIO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG. ASURE
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN. SUCI
THIS AREA QUINN O'DONNELL
ALISON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK BERG
SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE TEAM VALIDATORS THE
APPROVED BY VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN. MR BERMAN. ON THIS MOST
SOLEMN OCCASIONS- OH LORD OUR
GOD. WE OPEN OUR HEARTS MINDS
AND SOULS TO YOU. LET US
REMEMBER THE SIX MILLION JEWS
AND THE ELEVEN MILLION NON JEWS
WHO WERE MURDERED IN THE
HOLOCAUST. LET US HONOR THE
HEROES THE MARTYRS THE
SURVIVORS AND THE VICTIMS. LET
US REMEMBER THAT WHILE THE
SHEER NUMBERS MAY SEEM TOO
GREAT TO GRASP THAT EACH ONE OF
THOSE LOST WAS A DAUGHTER. A
SON A MOTHER OR FATHER. EACH OF
US IN THIS CHAMBER TODAY HAS A
PHOTO AND SHORT BIO OF SOMEONE
BORN ON YOUR BIRTHDAY. WHO
PERISHED AT THE HANDS OF EVIL.
WE ASK THAT YOU HELP US TO
FOREVER REMEMBER THE STORIES WE
HEAR. THAT THESE MEMORIES BE
STRENGTHENED AND NEVER FADE. IN
THE HOPE THAT THOSE WHO
REMEMBER THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST WILL NOT REPEAT THEM. WE
ASK THAT YOU GIVE US THE WISDOM
TO LEARN FROM THE STARKEST OUR-
AND THE STRENGTH AND VIGILANCE
TO ENSURE THAT THE WORLD DOES
NOT SEE AGAIN. SUCH ATROCITIES.
NOT ONLY DO WE SAY NEVER AGAIN.
BUT WE IN THIS CHAMBER DEDICATE
OURSELVES TO USE OUR POSITIONS
OF POWER TO STAND UP TO EVIL
AND TO PROTECT THE OPPRESSED.
WHETHER THEY BE IN OUR OWN
CITIES AND DISTRICTS OR ACROSS
THE WORLD. ABOVE ALL WE PRAY
FOR SO LONG. FOR WHOLENESS AND
PEACE TO BE IN OUR MIDST NOW
AND FOREVER. PLEASE OH HOLY ONE
ANSWER OUR PRAYERS AND BRING US
A WORLD DEVOID OF HATRED FILLED
INSTEAD IT WITH PEACE. CAN YOU
HEAR A TONE MAY THIS BE GOD'S
WELL. AND MAY WE ALL STAY
TOGETHER AMEN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
MEMBERS THANK YOU YOU MAY BE
SEATED. MOVING TO READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
SOME OBSERVERS ACKERMAN
WEDNESDAY MARCH IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
ASSEMBLY MALE MEMBER MULLIN FOR
DEATH IN THE FAMILY.
MR BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WARD
INVOLVED AS BONTA RODRIGUEZ AND
BLOOM TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO ADD. SUNSET REVIEW
OF THE OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AS AN
AGENDA ITEM FOR THEIR JOINT
HEARING ON FRIDAY APRIL NINTH
AT NINE AM. IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS.
FOR THEIR HEARING ON TUESDAY
APRIL TWENTIETH. EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR STONE AND AB FOUR
THIRTY GRAYSON PENDING A REVIEW
OF REFERRAL FROM THE BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE. AND AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WEEKS AND
KALRA PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE THAT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AND FINALLY PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR CORK SILVA FROM THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
TO THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE PRISTINA GARCIA FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE AND
THEN BACK. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AND AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT COURT. FROM THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION. COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MAKING MATTERS
BECAUSE- LIVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE THE SECOND
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
TWENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH
THREE TEN NINETY SIX TENANTS IN
SEVENTY NINE TO TWENTY FOUR
WITH THEM IT'S FIVE SIXTY TWO
OF THE MEMBERS SIX THIRTY SIX
FORTY NINE FOUR NINE WITH A
MEMBERS FOURTEEN THE MEMBERS
978-310-7115 SIXTY NINE
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR FORTY ONE
OF THE MEMBERS THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE OF THE MEMBERS EIGHT EIGHTY
THREE OF THE MEMBERS. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS ONE
OF FOR THE MEMBERS 333-669-7792
EIGHTY TWO WITH A MINUTE SIX
HUNDRED WITH A MEMBER THREE
FORTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
FOURTEEN OH THREE WITH A MEMBER
OF SIX FIFTY TWO AND ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE HUNDRED. ARE THEY
ALSO BEGIN. READ AND-
AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE THIRD
READING FILE. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN ACR
FIFTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CABLE AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS TO PRESENT ACR.
FIFTY SIX. MEMBERS I PLEASE ASK
YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MR
GABRIEL MR GABRIEL PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY COMMUNITIES IN
THE UNITED STATES IN ISRAEL AND
AROUND THE WORLD OBSERVE YOM
HASHOAH. HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY. FOR THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
IT IS THE ANNUAL COMMEMORATION
OF SIX MILLION JEWS AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS MORE BRUTALLY
MURDERED BY THE **** REGIME.
PROJECTS CAUCUS IN A CAPITOL
COMMUNITY TODAY MARKS THE FIRST
TIME IN RECENT MEMORY THAT WE
WILL OBSERVE YOM HA SHOAH
WITHOUT HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
JOINING US HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE COUNTED
ON THE SURVIVORS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND AN INCOMPREHENSIBLE
EVENT. THEY WERE OUR HEROES AND
OUR GUIDEPOSTS LIVING REMINDERS
OF OUR SACRED DUTY NEVER TO
REMAIN SILENT. WELL THERE
ABSENCE TODAY IS DEEPLY FELT
OUR OBLIGATION TO RECORD RECALL
THE HORRORS OF THE HOLOCAUST IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER. IN
TOO MANY PLACES AND ESPECIALLY
FOR TOO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE THE
HOLOCAUST IS FADING FROM VIEW.
AT THE SAME TIME ACTS OF ANTI
SEMITISM AND OTHER FORMS OF
HATRED AND BIGOTRY ARE RISING
AT AN ALARMING RATE. FUELED BY
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
AMPLIFIED BY THE EXTRAORDINARY
POWER OF SOCIAL MEDIA. THE WORK
BEFORE US IS PRESSING AN URGENT.
IN AN EFFORT TO PERSONALIZE
THAT WORK THE JEWISH CAUCUS HAS
PROVIDED EACH OF YOU WITH A
PRINTED TWEET FROM THE OFFICIAL
AUSCHWITZ MEMORIAL TWITTER
PAGE. WHICH HELPS TO PRESERVE
THE MEMORY OF THE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE WHO PERISHED IN
THE DEATH CAMP AT AUSCHWITZ
BIRKENAU. EACH TWEET TELLS THE
STORY OF A VICTIM OF THE
HOLOCAUST WHO SHARES YOUR
BIRTHDAY. A SMALL WINDOW INTO
THE DEVASTATION FROM WHICH
ENTIRE FAMILIES AND ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES NEVER RECOVERED. IN
MY CASE IT'S A TWEET ABOUT A
YOUNG BOY NAMED ABLE BACK. ON
HIS FOURTH BIRTHDAY ABLE WAS
DEPORTED FROM FRANCE TO POLAND.
TWO DAYS LATER HE WAS KILLED.
WHEN I LOOK AT A BOTH PICTURE I
CAN'T HELP BUT SEE MY SON
JOSHUA WHO SHARES MY BIRTHDAY.
AND ABLE. JOSH IS AN
EXCEPTIONALLY SWEET AND HAPPY
KID. A TRUE BLESSING FOR OUR
FAMILY. AND IT'S JUST A FEW
MONTHS HELP TURN FOR. WHICH
MEANS HE'S GOING TO BE THE SAME
AGE THAT ABLE ONCE WHEN HE WAS
STRIPPED OF HIS COMMUNITY
SHOVED INTO A CATTLE CAR AND
PUSHED INTO A GAS CHAMBER. LIKE
MANY OTHER JEWISH PARENTS I
CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER IF SOME
DAY. SOMEBODY WILL TRY TO HER
JOSH WILL BECAUSE WORKING WITH.
YOU SEE FOR THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY THE HOLOCAUST ISN'T A
DISTANT MEMORY. THE NEW YORK OF
JEWISH HISTORY TO RECENT EVENTS.
A PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING
CHAPTER IN A BOOK FILLED WITH
PAINFUL STORIES OF PERSECUTION.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME THE
HOLOCAUST EXEMPLIFIES THE
ENDURING RESILIENCE OF OUR
PEOPLE OF OUR SURVIVAL AGAINST
ALL ODDS PUNCTUATED BY THE
RETURN TO OUR HOMELAND AFTER
TWO THOUSAND YEARS. OF FORCED
EXILE. AND IT'S ALSO A CALL TO
ACTION. THE ULTIMATE REMINDER
OF HOW QUICKLY IN ADVANCED
EDUCATED AND MODERN SOCIETY CAN
UNRAVEL. OF HOW EASILY HATEFUL
RHETORIC CAN TURN PEOPLE
AGAINST THEIR NEIGHBORS AND
LEAD TO UNSPEAKABLE VIOLENCE.
OF OUR SACRED OBLIGATION TO
SPEAK OUT WHENEVER AND WHEREVER
BASELESS HATRED REARS ITS UGLY
HEAD. FOR ME FOLLOWING THE
AUSCHWITZ MEMORIAL ON TWITTER
PROVIDES THE DAILY MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. A REMINDER OF WHY
DO THE WORK. AND OUR HOPE IS
THAT SOME OF YOU IN THIS
CHAMBER WILL DECIDE TO START
FALLING MUSEUM ON TWITTER. AND
THAT THE TWEETS PROVIDED TODAY
WILL SERVE AS A REMINDER OF OUR
COLLECTIVE OBLIGATION. TO
ENSURE THAT NOTHING LIKE THE
HOLOCAUST HAPPENS EVER AGAIN.
TO ANY COMMUNITY OR IN ANY
COUNTRY. THANK YOU FOR HELPING
US TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF THOSE
WHO PERISHED IN THE HOLOCAUST
AND FOR STANDING WITH US AS WE
WORK TO OVERCOME ANTI SEMITISM
HATRED AND BIGOTRY OF ALL FORMS.
I ASKED THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CORPS AUTHORS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MISTER WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AT ALL TO BE G. Q.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT AND ACR FIFTY SIX.
TODAY WE REMEMBER THOSE WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES DURING THE
HOLOCAUST IN HONOR OF THOSE WHO
SURVIVED THIS HEINOUS ATTEMPT
AT EXTERMINATION. MANY GROUPS
ARE TARGETED AND PERSECUTED IN
THE HOLOCAUST ALONGSIDE THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY INCLUDING AND
ESPECIALLY THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
HITLER AND THE **** PARTY
TARGETED DEMAND BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE QUOTE.
UNFIT TO DEFEND THE NATION IN
COMBAT AND WOULD DIMINISH THE
GERMAN REPRODUCTIVE PTENTIAL.
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS LGBTQ
INMATES WERE KEPT IN SEPARATE
FACILITIES FOR THE FEAR THAT
HOMOSEXUALITY WOULD SPREAD IT
TO OTHER PRISONERS. RUDOLPH
RAZA WAS ONCE A SURVIVOR HE WAS
INTERNED IN BOOK INVOLVED AS
TRIANGLE NUMBER SEVEN NINE FIVE
TWO UNTIL IS LIBERATION BY U.
S. FORCES IN NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. BEFORE HIS PASSING IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN MISTER BRONSON
WAS THE LAST KNOWN
CONCENTRATION CAMP SURVIVOR TO
WEAR THE PINK TRIANGLE. AND THE
EMBLEM HOMOSEXUALS HAD TO WEAR
THE L. G. B. T. Q. EQUIVALENT.
OF THE YELLOW JEWISH STAR. WILL
HE BE IT A POINT TO SHARE STORY
OF THE L. B. T. VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
THIS STORY IS OFTEN OMITTED
FROM HOLOCAUST LITERATURE AND
EDUCATION. IT WAS NOT UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND TWO THAT GERMANY
ACKNOWLEDGE AND APOLOGIZE FOR
THE HORRORS PERPETRATED BY THE
**** TARGETING THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. WE NEED TO SPREAD
AWARENESS OF RUDOLPH'S STORY
AND THE STORY OF ALL THOSE
PERSECUTED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
AND AS WE SHARE THE STORIES WE
MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT HE IS
STILL VERY MUCH ALIVE AND
PRESENT WITH US TODAY. LET'S
CONTINUE TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
COLLECTIVELY FIGHT AGAINST
ANYONE WHO CLAIMS THEIR
IDENTITY IS SUPREME. AND FIGHT
FOR A FREE. EQUITABLE AND SAFE
SOCIETY FOR ALL. YOU'RE EITHER
ON THE C. R. FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER WARD MISTER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR FIFTY SIX
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM WOODLAND HILLS
FOR BRINGING THAT MEASURE.
BEFORE US TODAY. THE HOLOCAUST
WILL FOREVER BE A STARK
REMINDER THAT WE MUST ALWAYS
LOOK TO OUR PAST. IN ORDER TO
INFORM OUR PRESENT. AND THE
FUTURE. WE MUST REFLECT UPON
OUR HISTORY PARTICULARLY ITS
DARKEST MOMENTS IN ORDER TO
LEARN FROM THE TRAGEDIES. THAT
HAVE BEFALLEN HUMANKIND AND
ENSURE THAT SIMILAR EVENTS.
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN AND- YOU
KNOW- OF FOR EACH OF THE
MEMBERS- AT LEAST OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL
COMMEMORATION BECAUSE EACH OF
US. NO PEOPLE. FROM OUR
FAMILIES WHO WERE LOST IN THE
HOLOCAUST OR WHO ARE AFFECTED
BY THE HOLOCAUST- WHO SURVIVED
THE HOLOCAUST. I'M WE STAND
HERE TODAY AT A TIME WHEN FEWER
AND FEWER INDIVIDUALS WHO
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED THE
HOLOCAUST TO REMAIN WITH US
THIS IS THE MARCH OF TIME IT'S
A FACT THAT WE LIVE WITH IN
FACT WE HONORED MANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS VERY FLOOR
OVER THE YEARS AND MANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO YOU MET AND
SHOOK THE HANDS OF- AND THANKS
FOR BEING HERE ARE GONE THEY'RE
NOT WITH US ANY LONGER. I HAD
THE OCCASION JUST COINCIDENTLY
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO I FLIPPED
ON THE TV AND I WAS LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING TO WATCH AND I- I
FOUND THAT THE THERE'S A
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT STEVEN
SPIELBERG WHO HUNT AND I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND IT TO YOU BUT- HI HE
RECEIVED AN ACADEMY AWARD. FOR
THE FILM SCHINDLER'S LIST- THEN
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE STORY. OF A
NON JEW WHO SAVED OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE- DURING THE
HOLOCAUST. AND ONE OF THE
VIGNETTE STARTS IN THIS
DOCUMENTARY IS THE APPLE LOG TO
THAT FILM WHERE. AFTER SEEING
THIS TRAGEDY UNFOLD IN THIS
VERY RIGHTEOUS INDIVIDUAL SAVE
SO MANY LIVES- AT THE SCENE
SHIFTS FROM **** GERMANY TO
PRESENT DAY ISRAEL AND DOZENS
AND DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO SURVIVED AND
WHO WERE SAVED BY OSKAR
SCHINDLER COME TO THE GRAVE. OF
SCHINDLER AND PLACE AS IS THE
JEWISH TRADITION- A MARKER A
STONE ON. THE MARKER- ON A
SYMBOL OF THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
NOT ALONE SOMEBODY HAS COME TO
VISIT YOU. STONE AFTER STONE
AFTER STONE IS PLACED ON THAT
MARKER. AND I WOULD IMPLORE
EACH OF YOU TO THINK OF THAT
STE OF THOSE STONES AS SYMBOLS-
WE EACH NEED TO PLACE STONES.
TO REMEMBER THE HOLOCAUST AND
WE SHOULD BUILD. COLLECTIVELY A
MOUNTAIN NOT A MOUNTAIN A
MOUNTAIN RANGE OF STONES.
TALLER AND WIDER THAN THE
MIGHTY SIERRA NEVADA THAT
SHOULD BE OUR LONG LASTING
MEMORIAL SO THAT WE NEVER
FORGET THE LESSONS OF THE
HOLOCAUST. THANK YOU I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF ACR FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR CANYON RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I
RISE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN
REMEMBERING WHAT HAPPENED TWO
YEARS AGO ON THIS FLOOR
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY AYE
ROSEN AYE DURING THE MEMORY OF
MY GRANDMOTHER WHO JUST PASSED
AWAY AT NINETY EIGHT YEAR
ALMOST NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD
AFTER SURVIVING THE HOLOCAUST.
BUT TODAY I WANT TO REMEMBER
SOMEONE DIFFERENT MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER- MAP BERMAN WAS
TINY SMALLER THAN ME WHICH IS
ALL OF YOU KNOW IT'S SAYING A
LOT. AND SHE WAS ONE OF THE
MOST LOVING PEOPLE I EVER KNEW
SHE ALWAYS HAD A NEW BEADED
NECKLACE FOR ME EVERY TIME SHE
SAW ME BECAUSE SHE KNEW I LOVED
IT. AND I'M STANDING HERE TODAY
BECAUSE ON NOVEMBER NINTH
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT. IRMA
BOUGHT TICKETS TO THE OPERA.
THAT'S IT FINE FEELING HERE THE
NEW KRISTALLNACHT WAS COMING
THE NEW THEY'RE GONNA BE
ROUNDED UP IN VIENNA AND SO SHE
TAUGHT BY TICKETS TO BE AN
OFFER AND THEY WENT THAT
EVENING DRESSED UP AND THEY
WENT TO THE OPERA. AND SO THEY
WERE ROUNDED UP. AND THEY FOUND
A WAY OUT A FEW MONTHS LATER.
BUT I SHOULDN'T JUST BE
STANDING HERE BECAUSE MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER BUY TICKETS TO THE
OPERA. I SHOULD BE STANDING
HERE BECAUSE MY FAMILY HAD
MEANS TO FIND A WAY OUT. THE
NEW SOMEONE OCEANS AWAY THAT
WOULD SPONSOR OUR FAMILY. AND
MUCH IS MADE OF SCHINDLER AND
THE OTHERS WHO DID SO MUCH WITH
SUCH BRAVERY. TO SAVE LIVES
DURING THE HOLOCAUST BUT I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO REMEMBER
THE PEOPLE. WHO LIVES OUTSIDE
THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS WHO
WOULD BE SHOWERED IN THE ASH OF
THOSE THAT WERE BEING BURNED IN
THE EVENTS IN THEIR OWN
NEIGHBORHOODS THEY DID NOTHING.
AND WE HAVE A CHOICE EVERY TIME
HEAT RISES UP. TO BE THE OSKAR
SCHINDLER'S. OR TO BE THE
PEOPLE WHO ALLOW THEIR KIDS TO
SWING ON SWINGS THAT'S COVERED
IN ASH OF THE LIVES OF THOSE
WHO ARE BEING BURNED. AND WE
HAVE STEPPED UP MEMBERS TO BE
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR STATE AND OUR NATION. AND
WE MUST REMEMBER OUR SOLEMN
OBLIGATION THE OBLIGATION THAT
ARE CALLING FROM SANTA MONICA
JUST SPOKE ABOUT. TO STAND UP
TO HATE IN ALL OF ITS FORMS.
BECAUSE THE HOLOCAUST DIDN'T
START WITH PEOPLE BEING BURNED
IN OVENS. THAT WAS ITS
CULMINATION. IT STARTED WITH
PROPAGANDA IN HEATS. AND MY
GRANDMOTHER BEING KICKED OUT OF
SCHOOL BECAUSE SHE WAS NO
LONGER WORTHY TO BE EDUCATED.
AND THEN IT ENDED IN THE LIVES
LOST THAT WE SPEAK ABOUT TODAY
YOU SEE SITTING ON YOUR DESKS.
AND SO WE MUST STAND UP AT THAT
FIRST MOMENT WHEN WE HEAR
PROPAGANDA TO SAY NO WE KNOW
WHERE THIS CAN LEAD. AND IT
JUST RECENT YEARS WE SON ****
MARCHING IN THE STREETS OF
AMERICA. MY GRANDMOTHER WAS
ALIVE TO SEE THAT. WE MUST BE
OF THE FORCE THAT STOPS THAT.
AND SO WE SPOKE RECENTLY ABOUT
THE ANTI ASIAN HATE THAT IS ON
A RISE WE TALK ABOUT THE ANTI
SEMITISM THE CONTINUES TO RISE
AND I AM FOR EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU TO USE TODAY TO REMEMBER
OUR OBLIGATION TO STOP IT TO
SPEAK OUT AND TO NEVER BE
SILENT SO THIS. NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN. SO ONE'S LIFE DOESN'T
COME DOWN TO WHETHER THEY BUY
TICKETS TO THE OPERA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CAN. SOME AMERICANS
AARON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF P. C. R. FIFTY SIX
FOR HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY.
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN RECOGNIZING. THIS
DAY AS WE ALL REMEMBER AND PAY
OUR RESPECTS TO THE MILLIONS OF-INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES UNDER THE ****
REGIME. WE MUST NOT FORGET THE
HORRORS THESE VICTIMS FACED
MORE THAN SEVENTY YEARS AGO AND
JUST AS IMPORTANTLY WE MUST NOT
FORGET THE FACTORS. THAT LED TO
THIS ATROCITY AS ELOQUENTLY
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE. JUST
PREVIOUSLY SPEAKING. WHEN THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WAS FIRST MET
WITH SILENCE ADOLF HITLER IN
PERSUADING HIS ARMY COMMANDERS
THAT THE MERCILESS PERSECUTION
OF KILLINGS OF JEWS AND OTHERS
WOULD BRING NO RETRIBUTION
DECLARED WHO AFTER ALL.
REMEMBERS THE ARMENIANS TODAY.
LESS THAN FOUR DECADES AFTER
THE HOLOCAUST ANOTHER GENOCIDE
OCCURRED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. A REGIME LED BY POL POT
EXECUTED NEARLY A QUARTER OF
CAMBODIA'S. AS WE REFLECT ON
THESE FRIGHTENING TIMES WE MUST
REMEMBER TO STAND WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND SPEAK OUT TO ENSURE
THAT THESE ACTS OF VIOLENCE ON
INDIVIDUALS OVER THEIR
BACKGROUNDS THEIR CULTURES
WHERE THEIR RELIGIONS WILL
NEVER OCCUR AGAIN. WE OWE IT TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO REMEMBER OUR
PAST AND LEARN IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH RESPECT AND
COMPASSION FOR ALL PEOPLE. I
STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE FOR
ACR FIFTY SIX AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK. MR LEVINE AND MR
GABRIEL AND THE ENTIRE JEWISH
CAUCUS FOR PROVIDING US WITH
THESE. FRAMED PHOTOS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO SHARE ALL OF
OUR RESPECTIVE BIRTHDATES- I
MAY NOT KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
BOLESLAW. JEFF AND WEBER EXCEPT
THAT HE WAS AN ELECTRICIAN AND
THAT HIS FATE IS UNKNOWN AS OF
OCTOBER TWENTIETH NINETEEN
FORTY TWO. AND I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE IF HE DOES HAVE ANY
SURVIVORS HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
NEVER BEING ABLE TO RECOVER.
WHERE HIS BODY LAY AND HOW HIS
LAST MINUTES WERE. AND IT'S
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT. THAT FATE
OF INDIVIDUALS. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT NEVER REPEATS
ITSELF AGAIN THANK YOU.
PARAPHYLETIC STILL INDUSTRY
VERY SPEECH THANK YOU MISTER.
THROUGH THE RECOGNIZE NEAR THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IS A MEMBER
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT
OF ACR FIFTY SIX WHICH
PROCLAIMS APRIL EIGHTH AS
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY AND
URGES REMEMBRANCE OF THE
VICTIMS WERE MURDERED NEARLY
EIGHTY YEARS AGO. THE
INDESCRIBABLE OF EVENTS WHICH
TRANSPIRED ROOTED IN FEELINGS
OF FEAR AND HATE FEELINGS THEY
CONTINUE TO PROCESS AS WE
STRUGGLE WITH THE ONGOING
CRIMES OF PERSECUTION AND
DISCRIMINATION. AGAINST
MINORITIES AND MANY COMMUNITIES.
TODAY WE MUST STAY VIGILANT
AGAINST THE DEHUMANISATION AND
PERSECUTION OF THOSE WHO ONLY
CRIME IS TO BE DIFFERENT. IT IS
THEREFORE OUR ROLE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO UPHOLD THE
RIGHTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
TO PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AS WE DO WE MUST ACTIVELY
REMEMBER THE STORIES OF THE
VICTIMS AND THE SURVIVORS OF
THE HOLOCAUST SOME CELEBRATING
THEIR LIVES AND MOURNING THE
PAIN. THAT THEY HAVE BEEN LURED
AND CONTINUES TO INDOOR. AND%
I'D LIKE TO END WITH JUST A
SHORT- STORY ANTIDOTE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. I WAS AWARDED A
FELLOWSHIP. FROM THE
ORGANIZATION OF AMERICAN STATES
THE OAS. TO TRAVEL TO PANAMA TO
THE JEWS OF PANAMA. AND AS I
WAS LOOKING THROUGH- THE
ARCHIVES I CAME ACROSS LETTERS
LETTERS FROM WORLD WAR TWO
WRITTEN BY PANAMANIAN JEWS. WHO
SENT MONEY AND LETTERS. IN
SUPPORT OF THE RELIEF EFFORTS
OF THE JEWS OF EASTERN EUROPE.
SO I AM PROUD TO STAND HERE IN
REMEMBRANCE AND SUPPORT ACR
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR NINETEEN AND ASSUMING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND DIE RISE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT OF ACR
FIFTY SIX- TO REMEMBER THE
HOLOCAUST ALL OF THE VICTIMS
I'M A I'M I'M AMAZED TO STAND
WITH YOU- NINE YEARS SEN. TO
BEING WITH MANY OF YOU HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT WE'VE
MARKED HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY TOGETHER AND THAT WE'VE-
EVOLVED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC TO
DO THIS IN- WHAT I BELIEVE IS
JUST AN EXTRAORDINARILY
POWERFUL AND MEANINGFUL WAY TO
CONNECT EACH OF US. TO A PERSON
WHO WAS MURDERED BY THE ****
IT'S EASY TO THINK ABOUT. THE
SIX MILLION JEWS THE ELEVEN
MILLION MURDERED. INNOCENT
PEOPLE. THAT WE CAN BE
OVERWHELMED BY THOSE NUMBERS.
AND TO LEARN. THE IDENTITIES.
TO SEE INTO. THE INNOCENT
SMILES THE JOYFUL FACES OR THE
EYES THAT ARE IN HORROR. IN
SOME OF THE SHOTS OF PRISONERS
WHETHER IT BE A POLISH OLYMPIAN.
TODDLERS STANDING TOGETHER OR-
IN MY CASE A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY WHOSE NAME DESERVES TO BE
READ JESUS DYING GEISER A HUNG
FROM HUNGRY HE WAS BORN ON MY
DESK ON MY BIRTHDAY IN NINETEEN
THIRTY AND WAS MURDERED AFTER
IS FOURTEENTH BIRTHDAY IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR IN THE GAS
CHAMBER AT AUSCHWITZ AND- AND
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM WOODLAND
HILLS I CAN'T STOP BUT THINK
ABOUT MY OWN FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
SON. WHO CELEBRATED HIS BAR
MITZVAH LAST YEAR AND WHAT THAT
WAS LIKE IN AND I WAS I WAS
THUMBING THROUGH THIS BOOK. AND
I IN PLEASE PLEASE DO. JUST
READ A FEW OF THE STORIES AND
LOOK INTO THE EYES. OF SOME OF
THE VICTIMS. THAT THAT- THAT
YOU LEARN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
EACH PERSON'S HUMANITY AND
THERE'S JUST THERE'S VERY
LITTLE ABOUT THIS BUT THERE WAS
ANOTHER FOURTEEN YEAR OLD BOY.
HE WAS A CHECK BOY. BORN ON THE
FOURTH OF SEPTEMBER NINETEEN
THIRTY. IN FRONT OF BASS. AND
PERMISSION READ MASSACRE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU AND
HE WAS DEPORTED TO REASONS DOT.
GHETTO IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN
FORTY ONE AND HE WROTE A POEM.
WHILE HE WAS THERE IN THAT
GHETTO. HE WAS MURDERED. IN
OCTOBER OF NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
BUT BEFORE HE WAS TRANSPORTED
TO AUSCHWITZ. HE WROTE THIS
POEM AT TREASON STAT AND HE
TITLED AT THE GARDEN. THE
GARDEN. A LITTLE GARDEN
FRAGRANT AND FULL OF ROSES. THE
PATH IS NARROW. AND A LITTLE
BOY WALKS ALONG IT. A LITTLE
BOY. A SWEET BOY. LIKE THAT
GROWING BLOSSOM. WHEN THE
BLOSSOM COMES TO BLOOM. THE
LITTLE BOY WILL BE NO MORE. HE
KNEW. BEFORE HE WAS TRANSFERRED
TO AUSCHWITZ WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THEM. AND SO MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD YOU
KNOW. I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR HELPING US REMEMBER
HIM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE MISTER JOHN SORRY
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST SUPPORT. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR ACR FIFTY
SIX RECOGNIZING TODAY AS
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY. ON THIS DAY WE MUST ALL
TAKE TIME TO REMEMBER THE
VICTIMS OF THE ANTI SEMITIC
GENOCIDE CARRIED OUT BY THE
**** REGIME YEARS AGO IT SHOW
SUPPORT FOR OUR JEWISH BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND EXPERIENCED PREJUDICE
TODAY. PEOPLE OFTEN WISH THAT
WE COULD SIMPLY BE RACE. THE
DARK STAINS FROM OUR HISTORY.
BUT WE DON'T BUT IF WE DON'T
REMEMBER THE ATROCITIES OF THE
PAST IF WE DON'T CONFRONT
HATRED. WE ARE AT RISK OF
ALLOWING THOSE MISTAKES TO
HAPPEN AGAIN. I'VE HEARD PEOPLE
SAY. THE HOLOCAUST NEVER
HAPPENED FOR SOME REASON OR
ANOTHER THESE ARE SOME. PLEASE
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
CLAIM BUT THE LARGEST GENOCIDE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE MODERN
WORLD NEVER HAPPENED. THEY
THINK IT WAS A HOAX. THAT IS A
VERY VERY SICKENING THOUGHT.
BLACK PEOPLE KNOW ALL TOO WELL
THE COST OF WHITE SUPREMACY IN
A TRUSTED IS COMMITTED DURING
THE HOLOCAUST MINORITIES ACROSS
THE GLOBE HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
WORST THE WORLD HAS TO OFFER IN
THE NAME OF PROTECTING A MASTER
RACE YET WE CONTINUE TO SEE
VIOLENCE PERPETRATED AGAINST
MINORITIES DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY AFTER DAY. AN ESTIMATED
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WERE
SYSTEMATICALLY MURDERED IN COLD
BLOOD IN THE NAME OF WHITE
SUPREMACY AND TODAY WE REMEMBER
THEM. BECAUSE WHEN WE IGNORE
HISTORY. WE ARE DOOMED TO
REPEAT IT. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WEEK
SUPPORT ACR FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER. YES
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR FIFTY
SIX. OF THE MILLIONS THAT
PERISHED DURING THE HOLOCAUST
WOMEN WERE SUBJECTED TO SOME OF
THE MOST INHUMANE TREATMENT.
MOTHERS WERE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES SOMETIMES BEING FORCED
TO CHOOSE WHICH ONE CHILD THEY
WOULD BRING WITH THEM IN A
MIRAGE OF THEIR ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO SAVE THAT CHILD WHICH
DID NOT HAPPEN. PREGNANT WOMEN
WERE FORCED INTO THE GAS
CHAMBERS FIRST SINCE THEY WERE
DEEMED INCAPABLE OF WORK AND
JUST TO REMIND PEOPLE WHEN THE
JEWS GOT OFF THE GAS CHAMBERS A
FEW OF THEM WERE SELECTED TO
WORK. THE REST WERE SENT
DIRECTLY TO REMOVE THEIR
CLOTHING AND MARCH DIRECTLY
INTO THE GAS CHAMBER SO THIS
WAS A VERY FAST ASSEMBLY LIKE
DE HUMANIZE PROCESS. JEWISH AND
GYPSY WOMEN WERE RAPED AND
TORTURED BY THE **** THEY WERE
SUBJECTED TO HORRIFIC
EXPERIMENTS THAT LEFT THEM
SCARRED AND STERILE. PART OF
REMEMBERING THE HOLOCAUST IS
ALSO REMEMBERING THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PERISHED WHICH
IS WHY YOU HAVE THE
COMMEMORATIVE- PLATES ON YOUR-
DESK TODAY WITH SOME OF THE
VICTIMS I WANT TO CALL OUT A
FEW MORE. THESE WERE WOMEN LIKE
CAROLINE FLIES NERVE WHO
ARRIVED AT AUSCHWITZ ON AUGUST
SECOND NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND
A TRANSPORT OF ONE THOUSAND
JEWS SHE DID NOT SURVIVE. THEY
WERE YOUNG GIRLS LIKE ON A
FLASHOVER WAS DEPORTED TO
AUSCHWITZ AT THE AGE OF FIVE
WITH HER BROTHER JOHN WHO WAS
SEVEN. THEY WERE BOTH MURDERED
IN THE GAS CHAMBERS. WOMEN ALSO
PLAYED KEY ROLES AS HEROES
SAVING VICTIMS AND LIBERATING
PRISONERS FIGHTING IN THE
RESISTANCE AND FINALLY HOLDING
ALL THOSE WHO COMMITTED THESE
TERRIBLE CRIMES ACCOUNTABLE
THEY WERE HER ROPE WOMEN LIKE
HEY COULD GROSSMAN ONE OF THE
ORGANIZERS OF THE BLS DOC
UNDERGROUND THE OTHER STOCK BY
THE WAY IS WHERE MY
GRANDMOTHER'S FAMILY IS FROM.
BRAVE WOMEN LIKE ALLAH GERBNER
REGINA SAPPERS AND ESTHER WEST
PALM AND ROSA ROPE TO WHO
SUPPLIED THE GUN POWDER. THAT
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH SONQOR
COMMANDO AT AUSCHWITZ USED TO
BLOW UP A GAS CHAMBER AND KILL
SEVERAL ASSESSMENT DURING THE
UPRISING. IN OCTOBER OF
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. AND THERE
IS A FICTION BY THE WAY THAT
JEWS AND OTHER VICTIMS MARCHED
LIKE SHEEP INTO THE GAS
CHAMBERS AND THIS WAS NOT TRUE
THERE WERE MANY UPRISINGS
THROUGHOUT THE HOLOCAUST. THERE
WERE MANY RESISTANCE FIGHTERS
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
SIMPLY. NOT JUST OUTLINED BUT
THEY HAD AN ENTIRE NATION THAT
WAS CMPLICIT. AND ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATING WITH THE ****
AGAINST THEM AND THAT'S
SOMETHING TO ALWAYS REMEMBER.
THEY WERE THE DAUGHTERS OF
LIBERATORS AND RESISTANCE
FIGHTERS LIKE MY DEAR FRIEND
KRISTA MILLER WHO LOST HER
PARENTS AND EMERGE FROM WORLD
WAR TWO WITHOUT HER FAMILY AND
WITHOUT A HOME. CHRISTA'S
FATHER WAS PART OF THE GERMAN
RESISTANCE AGAINST HITLER IN
PARIS AND THE FAILED PLOT TO
ASSASSINATE HITLER IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR. HE WAS EXECUTED
ALONG WITH HER MOTHER. AND HER
FAMILY WAS FORCED INTO
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND HELL'S
WORTH OTHER TRADER CHILDREN OF
REBELLIOUS SS OFFICERS. TODAY
WE PAY TRIBUTE TO ALL THE WOMEN
AND THEIR ROLE IN ONE OF THE
DARKEST CHAPTERS IN OUR
HISTORY. WE HONOR THEIR
SACRIFICE INDOMITABLE STRENGTH
AND SPIRIT. WE REMEMBER OF THE
INDIVIDUAL ACTS OF BRAVERY
PERSEVERANCE AND LEADERSHIP.
AND YOU KNOW ON THIS DAY EVERY
YEAR WE SAY NEVER AGAIN. BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE
HEAD WE HAVE HAD SEVEN
RECOGNIZE WORLDWIDE RECOGNIZED
GENOCIDE SINCE THE HOLOCAUST.
AND THIRTY SEVEN INCIDENTS
WHICH MANY ARGUE COULD RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF GENOCIDE. SO WE
NEED TO ALWAYS BE ACTIVE AND
DELIBERATE. AND AS HAS BEEN
PORTED OUT GENOCIDES DON'T
ALWAYS START WITH PEOPLE
SHOOTING THEY DON'T START WITH
BEING PEOPLE BEING PUSHED INTO
THE GAS CHAMBERS. THEY START
WITH A CASUAL ACCEPTANCE OF
HATRED. OF RACISM AND
ANTISEMITISM ALLOWING THOSE
TROOPS TO GO ON ANSWERED. WE
NEED TO SPEAK OUT WE NEED TO
PROMISE THAT WE WILL SPEAK OUT
WHEN WE SEE THOSE ENORMOUS WHEN
WE SEE JEWISH CANDIDATES. HAVE
FLYERS AGAINST THEM WHERE THEY
ARE JEWISH FEATURES THEIR NOSES
ARE ELONGATED ONE DOLLAR BILLS
ARE PLASTERED OVER THEIR FACES
WE HAVE SEEN THAT IN MY TIME
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE. WE
NEED TO SPEAK OUT WHEN WE HEAR
JEWS ON THE WORLDWIDE STAGE
UNIQUELY CALLED OUT AND YOU
LEGALLY HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD. THAN OTHER
NATIONALITIES WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE WHEN PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT JEWS CONTROLLING THE
MEDIA OR CONTROLLING THE BANKS
OR BEING GREEDY OR BEING RICH
THAT THESE ARE THE SAME ANTI
SEMITIC TROPES THAT PEOPLE USED
TO JUSTIFY THE EXTERMINATION.
OF AN ENTIRE PEOPLE. THAT IS
WHAT IT REALLY MEANS TO NEVER
FORGET. WITH THAT I URGE A VOTE
ON A NAY VOTE ON A CA FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR
GABRIEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I FIRST
WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND ALL THE OTHER
CAUCUSES IN PARTICULAR FOR
THEIR- VERY POWERFUL AND
ELOQUENT WORDS AND I. HAVE TO
SAY ON A PERSONAL LEVEL MEANS
SO MUCH TO ME AND SO MUCH TO
OUR JEWISH CAUCUS FOR. THE
OTHER CAUCUSES AND FOR
COLLEAGUES FROM ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND PARTS OF THE
STATE TO STAND WITH US AND WHY
WE FEEL SO COMMITTED TO STAND
WITH THE API CAUCUSES THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH. THIS
EXTRAORDINARY SURGE IN AB I
HATE ALL OF THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE INDOOR TRAUMA. SO THINKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT OUR OUR
SURVIVORS ARE LEAVING US IN SO
MANY FOLKS WHO HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THE HOLOCAUST
ARE. OUR DEPARTED AND I WAS
REMINDED I KEPT THINKING THIS
WEEK OF A STORY. THAT WAS TOLD
TO ME BY A VERY PROMINENT
JEWISH COMMUNITY LEADER BY THE
NAME OF LERI WEINBERG FROM LOS
ANGELES SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL.
OUR CALLING FROM SANTA MONICA
AND I TURNED THIS BODY IN HIS
MEMORY. A FEW MONTHS AGO HE WAS
OF A SELF MADE PROMINENT.
BUSINESS EXECUTIVE VERY
INVOLVED AS A POLITICAL
ACTIVIST MOST WELL KNOWN FOR
OWNING THE PORTLAND
TRAILBLAZERS AND SERVING AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE NBA. I HAD THE
CHANCE ON A FEW OPPORTUNITIES
TO SPEND TIME WITH LARRY. AND
ON ONE OF THOSE ASKED HIM A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW HE BECAME
SO INVOLVED IN POLITICS. HE
TOLD ME A STORY ABOUT HOW
BEFORE. HE HE LIVED IN
CALIFORNIA HE WAS THE VICTIM OF
A POOR IMMIGRANT JEWISH FAMILY
LIVING IN BROOKLYN. AND IN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE SIGNED
UP TO GO FIGHT THE **** IN
EUROPE ANY OTHER SERIES OF
EXTRAORDINARY EXPERIENCES THERE
HE WAS. BAYONETED BY GERMAN
SOLDIER HE SUFFERED ANTI
SEMITISM FROM AMERICAN SOLDIERS
IN HIS OWN RANKS. BUT AT THE
END OF THE WAR YET A
PARTICULARLY MOVING EXPERIENCE.
HE WAS A- HIS UNIT WAS WITH
MOVING THROUGH. THROUGH THE
COUNTRYSIDE IN EUROPE. AND THEY
THEY ENCOUNTERED SOMEONE WHO
CAME OUT OF THE WOODS AND HE
WAS EMACIATED AND- I'M DRESSED
AND DRESSED IN RAGS AS LARRY
TELLS WITH AND- YOUR DIRTY
FILTHY AND HUNGRY. AND SOME OF
THE SOLDIERS IN HIS UNIT WHO
HAD HEARD REPORTS OF A PHOTO OF
AMERICAN G. I.'S WITH LIBERATED
CONCENTRATION CAMPS PUT
TOGETHER SAID THIS IS THIS IS
PROBABLY HOW CUSTOMER. SOMEONE
WHO'S WHO'S BEEN A RESISTANCE
FIGHTER IN THE WOODS AND- THE
MAN WAS VERY AGITATED AND THEY
COULDN'T REALLY COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM. AND SO THEY SAID GET
WEINBERGER COULD YOU MAYBE HE
CAN TALK TO HIM. AND SO WARY
LIKE MY- IMMIGRANT JEWISH
FAMILY SPOKE YET IF IT'S A
LANGUAGE WITH THE COMBINATION
OF HEBRON GERMAN. WE WENT UP TO
THE MAN AND HE SAID AND YOU
KNOW SHE SAID TO ME SO IT'S
OKAY. SO YOU'RE OKAY. SENATE
WHERE AMERICAN SOLDIERS I'M
JEWISH WE'RE HERE WE'RE HERE TO
PROTECT YOUR- THE MAN LOOKS AT
LARRY. HE SPITS IN HIS FACE HE
SAYS YOU'RE TOO LATE- TRUE LATE
AND HE WALKS AWAY. AND SO AS
LARRY TELLS IT THAT'S WHAT
INSPIRED HIM TO GET INVOLVED IN
POLITICS LARRY WENT ON TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE TO BE AN
ADVISER TO A NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES WE ALWAYS ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET INVOLVED IN
POLITICS YOU SPOKE UP. VERY
POWERFULLY ON CIVIL RIGHTS WAS
VERY FOCUSED ON ISSUES OF HUMAN
RIGHTS THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD. WE ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE YOUNG PEOPLE TO RUN
FOR OFFICE YOU ALWAYS BELIEVE
THAT POLITICS AND GETTING
INVOLVED IN SPEAKING UP EARLY
BEFORE TOO LATE WITH THE
ANTIDOTE WITH THE WAY THAT WE
PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE THE
HOLOCAUST NEVER HAPPENED AGAIN
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM FROM
DANVILLE PUT IT SO ELOQUENTLY
ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM. HAVE A
SPECIAL OPPORTUNITY AND A
SPECIAL OBLIGATION IN THE WAY
THAT WE COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER IN THE POLICIES THAT
ADVANCE AND THE BEHAVIOR THAT
WE MODEL IN A DIVERSE
PLURALISTIC MULTI ETHNIC
DEMOCRACY FOR HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE THIS EVER
HAPPENS AGAIN AND IT STARTS
WITH SPEAKING OUT EARLY. SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN THIS WORK I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE-
BEAUTIFUL COMMENTS AND HELPING
TO. MEMORIALIZE THE SIX MILLION
JEWS AND COUNTLESS OTHERS THAT
WERE MURDERED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. ON ACR
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
GARY WOULD YOU LIKE A VIRTUAL
THE OPEN FOR COST. YES THANK
YOU. CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
OFFER. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A
THIRD OF IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THOUGH THERE
SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ANY C.
R. FIFTY SIX WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING BACK TO FILE
ORDER WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB FOR NINETY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH INSURANCE IF YOU ARE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THE SUPREME COURT
CORD ORAL ARGUMENTS ON THE
FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THE
SUPREME COURT FINDING IN FAVOR
OF THE CHALLENGE COULD RESULT
IN THE ACA BEING OVERTURNED IN
ITS ENTIRETY OR IN PART.
PROBLEMATIC FOR MANY REASONS
ONE OF WHICH IS THAT MANY
HEALTH INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS
IN STATE LAW TIED BACK TO THE
ACA. FOR EXIT EXAMPLE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF MINIMUM
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS. AND
THE PROHIBITION AGAINST PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS. THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. AB FOUR
NINETY THREE REMOVED THE
REFERENCE TO FEDERAL LAW IN THE
STATE LAW THAT CONTINUE. TO USE
THE ISSUANCE OF HEALTH COVERAGE
TO ANYONE. WHO APPLIES THAT
PROTECTS PEOPLE WITH PRE
EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT
REQUIRES INSURERS TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS. AND
THAT LEOPARDS LIVE LIMITS
DIFFERENCES IN PREMIUMS TO AGE
AND GEOGRAPHY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER WOULD SEEM HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
BUSINESS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. OUR MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE
WHO. I FIFTY NINE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
THE RETAINER FILE ITEMS THIRTY
THROUGH THIRTY TWO MOVING THE
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TWO
FIFTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS
AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MISTER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS SO I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE ASSEMBLY
BILL. TWO FIFTY ONE WHICH
RECENTLY PASSED SO UNANIMOUSLY
OUT OF ALL. ASSEMBLY HEIAU
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB TWO THE
ONE WHERE YOU BRING NECESSARY
CLARIFICATION- TO THE COLLEGE
ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION PROCESS
AT OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND ALL
HELP PROTECT THE THIS IS A
PROCESS UP AGAINST THE FRAUD
AND ABUSE. AS YOU ARE ALL AWARE
ABOUT THE TWO YEARS AGO OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
TO WORST TAKEN BY THE LARGEST
ONCOLOGY ADMISSION IS A SCANDAL
IN THE HISTORY OF ALL OF THE
UNITED STATES- WHAT BECAME
KNOWN AS OPERATION VARSITY
BLUES SO INVOLVED US SEVERAL
YEARS OF- INVESTIGATION BY THE
F. B. R. Y. AND THE ARREST ALL
VOCAL FIFTY INDIVIDUALS ARE
INVOLVED. IN RECORD TEARING
BRIBERY AND WIRE FRAUD IN ORDER
TO SECURE ADMISSIONS ARE AT OUR
ELITE UNIVERSITIES SO FOR THE-
CHILDREN. FORTUNATELY THE
CALIFORNIA THE LEGISLATURE ROSE
TO THE OCCASION IN ACTING AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHICH
AMONG. OTHER THINGS SO OF. ROTH
IMPORTANT. TO THE ADMISSION BY
PROCESS OF WHICH ALLOW THE UC
TO ENROLL UP TO A 6% OF ALL ITS
APPLICANTS SO WHO DO NOT TO
MEET THE UC ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS BUT OTHERWISE SO
DEMONSTRATES. HOW YOUR
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE HOME AGAINST THE
KIND OF ABUSE SO WE SAW IN THE
OPERATION VARSITY BLUES SCANDAL
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRED THIS ADMISSION OF BY A
GOOD EXCEPTIONS CANDIDATES
OUGHT TO BE REVIEWED BY A PANEL
OF THE THREE SENIOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATORS. HOWEVER IT DID
NOT DEFINE COOL AT THE CAMPUS
OF COULD OR COULD NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE ADMISSION BY
EXCEPTION PROCESS. S. CI
ASSEMBLY OHIO EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ALL POINTS
OUT A SINCE THE DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE IS ARE NOT ALWAYS OF THE
ONLY DEPARTMENT CHARGES WITH
THE CAMPUS OF DEVELOPMENT AND
THE FUNDRAISING AT THE UC OR
CSU. A. TOOL FIFTY ONE REMOVES
THE ANY DOUBT OF WHAT ONE DO
YOU WANT HIM IMPROPER.
INFLUENCE NOT LET ME. OUR
DECISIONS ARE BY. A STEP ON IT
WITH THE EXTERNAL RELATIONS
ACTIVE SO FROM PROVIDING AN
ADMISSION DECISION FOR INCOMING
STUDENTS. CALIFORNIA YES SO
HOME TO THE MOST EXCEPTIONAL
HIGH OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
THE WORLD IT IS SO TREASURED
THE CHORE AND A CENTRAL 12-1
STRIKES US AS ON ONE OF THE
STRONGEST OR THE ECONOMICS ARE
AND THE VIBRANT DIVERSE A
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY.
HAVING RECEIVED A QUALITY
EDUCATION AND EVENTUALLY MY PHD
MYSELF OR I PERSONALLY KNOW. I
WOULD NOT BE STANDING HERE
BEFORE YOU AS OUR MEMBER- IF IT
WERE NOT FOR MY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. WE TO TAKE EVERY
STEP TO PRESERVE IT IS TO
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THE
PROTECT AGAINST THE TOP JOB
ABUSES AND THE FRAUD ON THAT
WAS SO WE'VE REVEALED THAT JUST
A TOOL YOU KNOW SO GO. SB TWO
FIFTY ONE BUILDS UPON IMPORTANT
STEPS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ADMISSION. BY EXCEPTION PROCESS.
AND ENSURE FURTHER. EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO A TO QUALITY HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR ARE YOU SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S FOR THESE RASONS
I RESPECTIVELY ASK ALL. OF YOUR
AYE VOTE THE HORN A. B. TWO
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHOI MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A JOINT AUTHOR WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE. HAS
HE SAID TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE
ROCKED BY THIS COLLEGE
ADMISSION SCANDAL IN OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES HE MEETS IN THE
NEW NETFLIX DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
THE OUTRAGEOUS FRAUD AND OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM WE DID
SOME LEGISLATION THAT YEAR THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOLLOW UP TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE APPROPRIATE CHECKS
AND BALANCES THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THESE
ADMISSIONS PROCEDURES. ARE NOT
IN ADDITIONALLY ARE NOT
ADDITIONALLY INVOLVED IN
FUNDRAISING OPERATIONS AT THEIR
MEASURE ASK THE RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THIS HAS BECOME
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO- SAID
WELL ALLUDED TO IT WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT VARSITY BLUES. AND
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WAS GOING ON
THERE BUT GUESS WHAT. THE SAME
THING. HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IT IS
YOU SEE. IT IS CSU. WHERE THE
STUFF WERE THE SAME THINGS WERE
HAPPENING IS VERY DOCUMENTED
WITH THE UC SYSTEM WE HAVE A
CITY IN REGENT. A CITY REGION
HUSBAND OF A U. S. SENATOR.
WRITING LETTERS OF SUPPORT FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS. AND HELPING
INFLUENCE ADMISSIONS DECISIONS
IN OUR HIGHEST- PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE
NOBODY'S REALLY BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT AND WE NEED TO DO A
WHOLE LOT MORE TALKING ABOUT IT
THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP. BUT
WE GOT A WHOLE LOT MORE TO DO
TO ENSURE THAT YOU THERE IS
ACTUALLY QUALITY. IN ADMISSIONS
AND THAT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
NEPOTISM IS ALIVE AND WELL. IN
THE UC SYSTEM AND THE AUDIT
SHOWED THAT. AND SO WE NEED TO
DO A WHOLE LOT MORE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS TRUE EQUALITY IN
THE MID IN ADMISSIONS. AND THAT
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS
FUNDRAISING RELATIONSHIPS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHETHER OR
NOT YOU GET INTO A YOU SEE. SO
THANK YOU MEMBERS ASKED THAT WE
CONTINUE THIS. CONTINUE TO MAKE
THESE TYPES OF REFORMS TO
ENSURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER. HEARING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER TRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I'VE WORKED. WELL OPEN THE
ROLE. VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
OUR MEMBERS SAID HE'S ALREADY
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES. PASS
A RETAINER FILE ITEMS THIRTY
FOUR THROUGH THIRTY SIX THE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. MOVING
A FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE AB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE MATTER
THANK YOU. OUR SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTY SIX IS A
BILL THAT WOULD EXPAND THE LIST
OF BUSINESSES. WHO QUALIFY
UNDER THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS STEP. ARE THE FOCUS OF
OUR BILL IS LOOKING AT THE
MANUFACTURING OF CLEAN FUEL
FOR. TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES IN
THE PRODUCTION OF ALTERNATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH
VEHICLES- THAT- ARE PART OF OUR
STATE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES SO
THANK YOU AND RESPECT
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE BY SEVENTY ONE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
FORTY THROUGH.
FORTY TWO.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING. TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEMS FORTY FOUR THROUGH
FORTY SIX THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS
ON TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSUMING
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER CHAO
RELATIVE TO WORLD ALSO AUTISM
AWARENESS DAY SOMEONE CURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN RELATIVE
TO DROWNING PREVENTION AND
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL LIBRARY WEEK. THE
CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO OUT ON IT.
THESE RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS THIS
VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORSON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE THERE
ARE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO A VOTE ON TODAY'S
CONTENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM FILE
ITEMS FORTY THREE THROUGH FIFTY
ONE DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A CONTENT CALENDAR. LEVIN TO
BUY SOME REMEMBER LOW AN
ACCOLADE IN HEALING ARTS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESERTED BOTH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FIVE I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SOME OF THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY
ONE I SEVENTY TWO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY ONE I
SEVENTIES YOU KNOW ZERO SOME
LEGAL FOR YOU TO I. SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY SIX HI SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SUM AGO SIX EIGHTY SEVEN I
SEVENTIES YOU KNOW ZERO
ANDERSON THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE. FIVE
SEVEN. ZERO WITHOUT. THE QUORUM
CALL WILL NOW BE LIFTED AND WE
WILL MOVE TO OURPREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADORNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADORNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN
IN GERMANY MEMORY. MR WARD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART AND RESPECT THAT I
RISE TODAY INTO DURING THE
MEMORY OF FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AND PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE GIN
MILLS. A PROUD NEED OF THE SAN
DIEGO SENATOR MILLS NEVER
MINISTRY CAR HE WOULD NOT RIDE
OR HISTORIC BUILDING THAT HE
WOULD NOT SAVE. JIM MILLS WAS
TRULY AN UNUSUAL POLITICIAN.
READ MORE VETERAN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL HISTORY TEACHER AND AN
INTELLECTUAL WHO WROTE A HALF A
DOZEN BOOKS OFTEN ABOUT
RELIGIOUS HISTORY. IN HIS
TWENTY TWO YEAR CAREER IN THE
LEGISLATURE HE WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN ISSUES SUCH AS
PASSION FOR MASS TRANSIT MANY
WAS IN POLITICAL GAMESMANSHIP.
DESPITE BEING VERY LIBERAL
FIRST TIME SENATOR MILLS
CONDUCTED HIMSELF AS A
TEMPERAMENTAL MODERATE
MASTERING THE SKILL OF HAVING
ACTED DISAGREEMENTS WITHOUT
BEING ACTIVELY DISAGREEABLE.
THIS ABILITY TO WORK
EFFECTIVELY ACROSS THE AISLE
GOT HIM APPOINTED PRESIDENT PRO
TEMPORE ADVISE COLLEAGUES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE A POSITION
THAT HE HELD UNTIL NINETEEN
EIGHTY. DURING HIS TIME AS A
LEGISLATOR SENATOR MILLS
AUTHORED BILLS THAT CREATED THE
SAN DIEGO TROLLEY. AND OLD TOWN
STATE PARK AS WELL AS AUTHORED
THE MILLS ACT WHICH IS CREDITED
FOR SAVING THOUSANDS OF
HISTORIC RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS FROM
DESTRUCTION ACROSS OUR STATE.
IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF HIS
PASSION FOR HIS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS.
SENATOR MILLS WAS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO THE
AMTRAK BOARD OF DIRECTORS WHERE
HE SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY
UNTIL NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. JIM
MILLS CONTINUED TO BE A PUBLIC
SERVANT AFTER ELECTED ALL AFTER
HE LEFT ELECTED OFFICE SERVING
AS THE CHAIR OF OUR
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN SAN DIEGO
FOR NINE YEARS. ITS
HEADQUARTERS WAS NAMED IN HIS
HONOR- OF SERVICE. SENATOR
MILLS. WAS A GIANT AND LOCAL
AND STATE POLITICS IS. HAS
CEMENTED HIS PLACE IN HISTORY
OF HOW. AND SAN DIEGO. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN KEEPING SENATOR
MILLS IN THIS FAMILY IN OUR
THOUGHTS AS WE IN TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AND PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A GIN
MILLS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WORDS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE FISHERMEN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU I ALSO
ADJOURNED MEMORY OF FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND SENATOR JIM
MILLS- LIKE SO MANY IN SAN
DIEGO I HAD THE BENEFIT OF
GETTING TO MEET THIS TRUTH.
GENTLE GIANT- WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC POLICY IN FACT HE KEY
SCHEDULED A MEETING WITH ME. AT
THE LABOR COUNCIL ALMOST A WEEK
AFTER I WAS ELECTED BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO BRING ME HAND. TYPED
PAGES OF HIS PLAN OF HOW I
COULD HELP PUBLIC TRANSIT-
SERVING AS THE HEAD OF LABOR
AND SO I'M SURE I DID NOT DO
ENOUGH. AND I'M SURE. HE WILL
ALWAYS REMAIN A GIANT IN IN
OUR- PERSPECTIVE IN SAN DIEGO
I'VE NEVER MET SOMEBODY WHO HAS
ANYTHING BUT A KIND WORD TO
SAY. ABOUT THE MAN WHO HAD DONE
SO MUCH FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT. AND
I THINK IT'S TELLING AND MAYBE
THE BEST. THE BEST TRIBUTE
POSSIBLE THIS HIS FAMILY SAID
RATHER THAN SEND FLOWERS THAT
IN ORDER TO REALLY- APPRECIATE
HIS MEMORIES THEY'VE ASKED
PEOPLE TO TAKE A RIDE ON A
TROLLEY A TRAIN OR BIKE.
GODSPEED SENATOR MILLS. THANK-YOU MISS GONZALES MR BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMORY IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IRISE
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF DOROTHY
KING. WHO PASSED AWAY FROM
BREAST CANCER ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH. AT THE AGE OF
SIXTY NINE KING WAS THE OWNER
OF A BAY AREA FAVORITE
RESTAURANT EVERITT. AND JONES
BARBECUE SHE WAS NOT ONLY
FAMOUS FOR HER FAMILY BARBECUE
RECIPES BUT ALSO AS A WELL
KNOWN ACTIVIST. COMMUNITY
LEADER AND ADVOCATE FOR THE
HOMELESS MS KING GREW UP IN
WEST OAKLAND WITH HER SEVEN
SISTERS AND ONE BROTHER. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE KINGS
MOTHER DOROTHY EVERITT OPENED
WHAT WOULD BECOME A STRING OF
BAY AREA FAMILY. BARBECUE
RESTAURANTS. GO THINKING
FOLLOWED IN HER MOTHER'S
FOOTSTEPS IN OPEN SEVERAL
BARBECUE ESTABLISHMENTS ONE
THAT HELPED REVITALIZE
OAKLAND'S JACK LONDON SQUARE.
BEING A BLACK FEMALE BUSINESS
OWNER CERTAINLY HAD ITS
CHALLENGES BUT KINGS FAMILY
PIERCED THE GLASS CEILING OF
LONGEVITY. FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS WOMEN AND FAMILIES IN
BUSINESS. EVER IN JONES
BARBECUE IS NOW A THIRD
GENERATION BUSINESS. NEW WEST
MAGAZINE CALLED EVERTON JONES
THE BARBECUE AGAINST WHICH ALL
OTHERS ANYWHERE. MUST BE
JUDGED. NOR THE KING WAS ALSO A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY OUR
HOMELESS NEIGHBORS AND THOSE.
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AS PART OF A RESTAURANT
BUSINESS SHE MADE A POINT OF
HIRING FORMERLY INCARCERATED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. HE FELT IT
WAS ON JUST THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY.
AND RETURN HOME HAD LITTLE OR
NO OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES SHE ALSO REGULARLY HIRED
HOMELESS COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AND
SEVERAL YEARS AGO KING BEGAN
FEEDING THE MANY HUNGRY AND
NEEDY EVERY NIGHT AFTER HOURS
AT HER JACK LONDON SQUARE
RESTAURANT. YOUR THINKING IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND JOHN
JERNIGAN FOUR DAUGHTERS AND TWO
SONS GRANDCHILDREN. HER
SIBLINGS AND MANY OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS FRIENDS CUSTOMERS AND
THE. GREATER COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS HER BELOVED YORKSHIRE.
APPROACH NAMED SAUCY. SHE LED A
LIFE AND LEAVES A LEGACY FULL
OF MEETING AN INSPIRATION. OUR
SPEAKER CALLING TO ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF DOROTHY KING. THANK
YOU MR BONTA AFTER SERVING AS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMANY MEMORY. MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RIGHT YOUR DURING
YOUR MEMORY OF CHINO CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER MARK HARGROVE.
MARK WAS A LONG TIME CHEN A
RESIDENT AND GRADUATE OF JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL. HE WAS AN ADVOCATE
FOR YOU SPORTS PARTICULAR OF
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH MANY
LOCAL CHARITIES. MARC SERVING
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHERE HE
WORKED TO THE RANK OF SERGEANT.
WHEN HE WENT TO WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS FOR THE NEXT THIRTY
YEARS. TWENTY OF WHICH WERE THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN IN
CHINO. AFTER RETIRING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR MEN.
AS A LIEUTENANT MARK WENT ON TO
SERVE THE PLANNING COMMISSION
FOR THE CITY A CHANNEL. DESPITE
HAVING TO BATTLE ILLNESS
SHORTLY SHORTLY AFTER TAKING
OFFICE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN MARK
CONTINUE TO SURFACE COMMUNITY.
PARTICIPATE ON CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS REPRESENTING THIS
COMMUNITY. MARK QUICKLY EARNED
THE RESPECT AND TRUST OF LOCAL
LEADERS AND WASTED NO TIME ON
TAKING ON CITY PROJECTS. MARK
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE TERRY
AND FAMILY. MEMBERS I ASKED YOU
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
AGREEMENT A MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN ARMY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF BASKETBALL LEGEND. ELGIN
BAYLOR. BAYLOR WAS BORN
SEPTEMBER SIXTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR IN WASHINGTON DC TO
JOHN AND UZIEL PALER. GROWING
UP HE LIVES NEAR RECREATION
CENTER BUT AFRICAN AMERICANS
WERE BANNED FROM USING THAT
FACILITY. AS A RESULT HE CAN
START PLAYING THE GAME THAT
WOULD MAKE HIM FAMOUS UNTIL HE
WAS FOURTEEN YEARS OLD. AS A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR BAYLOR'S
STANDING AT SIX FOOT FIVE AND A
HUNDRED NINETY POUNDS WAS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN TO BE
NAMED TO THE FIRST TEAM OF THE
WASHINGTON ALL METROPOLITAN. HE
ALSO WON THE LIVINGSTON TROPHY
AS THE AREA'S BEST BASKETBALL
PLAYER FOR THE YEAR NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR. THAT SAME YEAR HE
ESTABLISHED A NEW DC AREA
RECORD SCORING SIXTY THREE
POINTS IN ONE GAME. IN NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT THE VAN MINNEAPOLIS
LAKERS DRAFTED BAYLOR AS THEIR
NUMBER ONE PICK AT A TIME WHEN
THE TEAM WAS STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE. DRAFTING SOMEONE SO
TALENTED AND PROMISING. THIS
WAS SEEN AS THE MINNEAPOLIS
LAKERS LAST EFFORT TO SAVE THEFRANCHISE. AND OBVIOUSLY IT
WORKED. ACCORDING TO THE
MINNEAPOLIS LAKERS OWNER AND A
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE INTERVIEW
HE ADMITTED. F. L. CHEN HAD
TURNED ME DOWN THEN I WOULD
HAVE BEEN OUT OF BUSINESS THE
LAKERS CAN YOU IMAGINE THIS THE
LAKERS WOULD HAVE GONE BANKRUPT.
BAYLOR EARNED ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR HONORS IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
SEASON SETTING THE STAGE FOR
THE REST OF HIS CAREER. HE
WOULD GO ON TO PLAY FOURTEEN
SEASONS FOR THE MINNEAPOLIS AND
LA LAKERS EARNING NBA ALL STAR
HONORS ELEVEN TIMES WITH TEN
FIRST TEAM ALL NBA APPEARANCES.
AFTER RETIRING FROM BASKETBALL
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE BAYLOR
WENT ON TO SERVE AS A COACH FOR
THE NEW ORLEANS JAZZ AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF BASKETBALL
OPERATIONS FOR THE LA CLIPPERS.
HE WAS INDUCTED INTO THE
BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND IS
NUMBER TWENTY TWO JERSEY WAS
RETIRED BY THE LAKERS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. TODAY
THERE'S A STATUE HONORING ELGIN
BAYLOR AT THE STAPLES CENTER IN
LOS ANGELES. ACCORDING TO THE
NBA COMMISSIONER ELGIN BAYLOR
SET THE COURSE FOR MODERN NBA
AS ONE OF THE LEAGUE'S FIRST
SUPERSTAR PLAYERS. THE IMPACT
OF BAYLOR'S LIFE AND CAREER IS
CLEAR. ELGIN BAYLOR PASSED AWAY
LAST MONTH OF MARCH ON MARCH
TWENTY SECOND AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY SIX AND IS SURVIVED BY A
SISTER HIS WIFE ELAINE. AND
THREE CHILDREN AND I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED IN ELGIN BAYLOR'S
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER BLAIR
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THENAMES
TO THE DEATH THREE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY APRIL
NINTH NO FOR SESSION AND NO
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY APRIL
TWELFTH WORK SESSION AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAINED ALMOST SINCE
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MISTER BLOOM MOVED TO
MR GABRIEL SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL
MONDAY APRIL TWELFTH AT ONE PM.